book of boba fett episode 2 today
chapter dose time of filming this
doesn't have a thumbnail or a title so
we don't know what we're in store for
but guys if you go ahead and hit that
like button use the force i mean the
world subscribe and get accepted into
the reject nation so you get notified
when our reacts for the next boba fett
episode what's up what's up hey full
length watch along where you stick up
with the time code over at our patreon
page first reaction channel ever to come
up with that idea over there we cover so
many shows at the same tier you get the
option for reaction highlights and watch
alongs included lastly thanks to the
boys over at prepper for helping us edit
down these highlights let's get to it
[Music]
well if he's not going to speak
he no longer needs his head
there is no way he will talk they fear
no man fine
perhaps he fears the rancor oh my god
is it going to be moochie probably
i would say by the mayor the mayor sent
me
a record
it's empty
oh sweet tattooed why did you send this
man to assassinate me
i can assure you the mayor had nothing
he's a member of the order of
thank you for turning him in
give this man his reward
better than i expected and i will take
this payment
is what you should have brought me as
tribute
no response
i wonder if robert rodriguez played some
of these reworkings of the cantina music
she hired them what's going on here
in what respect mere moksha sent me here
as though there's something i should
know
now you're sweating like a gum down
mustafa
i said mustafar reference as
oh
[ __ ]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that is the coolest wookie i've ever
seen if you want it
you'll have to kill me for it
let's go get a burger instead
you know you could direct uh to address
it's cool how they talked in the last
episode about the crime lords they walk
in
carried yeah
gotta get that respect
let me continue my linear flashback
storytelling now got more badass
memories to relive
this guy's pretty good wow everyone's
really entertained by this yeah they're
taking bets
yeah all right
we're eating tonight
[Music]
everything you just learned boba you're
gonna have to do on that massive
creature
poor bantam
what a
weird gang
that's the same gang from uh the last
episode at the house they were torching
could be
do they have a big old train this train
just rides through pedestrians
trying to see anyone shoot
oh he's really one of them now
i
will stop the train i will take rifle
and stick be back by morning
they've got to be linked because those
dudes were on speeder bikes it's pretty
telling that he would return
he's got such great posture he does
and the tightest butt cheeks
[Music]
balls are universal nearly any race out
there that's right
the universal weak spot
another
yeah i'm phased by anything
this happens every week to this guy
yeah it's the same symbol that was on
the house a bit of a terminator two
thing
kind of with that yeah i was getting
started through the glass yeah she was
in the bike
like beat up a biker gang all he needs
to take somebody's leather jacket oh
damn he took a bunch
oh dude he's really going to rig for any
points today
[Laughter]
all i didn't know about tuscan raiders
guys
a gift
for you
[Laughter]
guys
these are mine
i will teach you
how to ride
i will teach you oh
damn this is how we will stop the train
i bring you technology
the advancement
okay go
stop
you must be so stinky boba
[Laughter]
it's just him though
tuscans are known for their
fabulous scent it's time to start racing
guys and now this is podrace
jump to me
jump
oh it's so cool
i like seeing them practice the job
that's funny
i love this
oh dude come on you had that
[Music]
now he's gonna do like eight flips
[Music]
oh yeah
they just always do that in action
movies
it's the first time i've ever seen them
like we're gonna practice the atlantic
like a choreography
[Applause]
are we doing i'm gonna try to hide the
mantha
god damn it teach the banta how to duck
or get them some armored plating or
something
love this man it's like cowboys
robbing a tree absolutely
oh god damn it
[Music]
oh
dang
my man
is awesome i know
the perfect blend
western in star wars
i forgot what kind of droid you're
called
[Laughter]
whoa yeah it's like sam raimi directed
that one yeah
[Music]
[Music]
wow such great details in this episode
oh
[ __ ]
oh yeah
even though it doesn't have wheels i
just got to mess you up
just hit stuff sit at all somehow
they're going to be approaching a canyon
it's going to go really yeah
there's a mine that's collapsing all the
best tropes
[Music]
dude
winch it
[Music]
and if you are to pass the toll
is to be paid to them any death doubt
from the passing freighters will be
returned tenfold
now go back to your syndicate and
present these terms syndicate
it's like mad max
you have machines now too
and you know
every grain of sand in the doom sea
i really underestimated the tuscan
raiders you know
i mean why gifted
i didn't do anything it was all you guys
i will let it guide me
whoa
oh my
oh i'm sorry
i think i swallowed it
[Music]
um
[Applause]
lsd
[Music]
boba waska
[Music]
oh
[Music]
whoa
that was a beautiful visual
memories overlapping themselves
[Music]
what did that lizard do to my brain
i have such a massive headache
wowie
that's that looks fun
oh
is that what they'll make his uh legit
weapon out of
[Music]
that was so cool was like breaking free
of the bonds of the past
being truly reborn
do i look badass let's try another look
this is what we do when we want to do
reactions
it's crazy how much the artwork
sometimes just looks so different
yeah whoa dean cundy shot this where's
baby yoda yeah where's grow gringo where
are you
and uh
you know all those other great kids
when's finn gonna show up
[Laughter]
nothing lends itself more
to correction police in the comments
then star wars videos i don't know this
character
black christian
took a photo and dropped it into google
okay it wasn't it seems like oh just
from the books and stuff hey
okay that's cool extended star wars
canon oh neato not bad and yes at one
point did work for and yes officially
credited on star wars fandom
for chapter two oh that's awesome cool
that's very cool
it was a badass looking character
definitely wouldn't have known that
no no no no chance it helped know that
yeah
um yeah i didn't read any of those books
my goodness but i'm glad to know it now
it must be very exciting for people who
did and did have passing because it
seemed like they had a history yeah so i
was like let me look this up because i
had to know but anyway i liked that
episode a lot i thought it was a much
bigger improvement upon
like a lot i know a lot of people seem
to be incredibly receptive to the first
episode
but this one was really my jam i drank
that bubba up
i drink your boba
see what i did dude you should open up a
boba theme a boba fett themed boba
restaurant like a cafe have like the
cantina music playing all the time the
only song you ever played there so it's
like a psychological torture that way
you know it's more badass than just
normal tea because you gotta have mental
fortitude
and that's what the episode was about
that's my takeaway no i agree this was a
really terrific episode and it was
certainly like
what
like i really liked the first episode it
presented a lot of really enjoyable and
really engrossing stuff but the expanded
nature of this episode i think really
packed the punch where i thought the
last one maybe fell a little bit short
of that or felt maybe a little less than
momentous you just don't like rob
rodriguez i hate he's not one of my
favorite directors of many years no i
just can't stand his movies i don't want
to see a little battle angel part two
or the spike you know what i'm not i'm
not setting you up anymore
terrific privileges have been revoked
buddy going on way too long anytime i
like robert
oh man
but steph green really killed it jeff
yeah seth green was excellent
killed it man
jumped from freaking robot chicken a
hero what do you know you never i never
thought he had it after this was
claymation i didn't even know i was
super impressed with that all right
let's try to get focused right now let's
get focused focused
up syndicate that's the thing that stood
out to me i i that could be in reference
to
uh well if
i've only done clone wars and rebels or
i'm not i'm not in the books and the
games and all that except for jedi fall
in order but my memory is so foggy and
all this stuff
um but yeah the seneca could be
referring to and even though darth maul
would be dead by this point in the
timeline that it still could be living
on at this point and in some form or
another or a shadow collective or
something so yeah it could be a
reference that which would be cool you
know uh obviously we wouldn't get darth
maul back in this show but to see where
the syndicate has evolved into by this
point would be neat
that's it for now talking about you know
star wars possible future in terms of
the immediate episode at hand
i really like the flashback stuff a lot
you know i haven't really i'm still
trying to figure out
i i wonder if you like you haven't been
on boba fett's journey through like the
animated series stuff uh especially
i could i could kind of fill in the
blank as to
why the motive to be where he's at
you know like he was involved with
gangs of all kinds when he was much
younger very revenge driven
as well and uh he he was thrusted into
positions where he was you know on the
outskirts the lower part of society and
he's had to make his way up as a bounty
hunter so i'm wondering
exactly like why the motivation to sort
of become
the you know the ultimate crime lord of
tattooing in particular
i
yet i feel like there is a purpose
that's going to be very established so i
could it's that kind of thing where i
can feel the feeling even though i don't
quite know why it is even though i could
probably fill in some some blanks that
he feels like he's probably owed this
by this point and the story clearly what
he knows yeah because he's had to become
number one bounty hunter to so many
people or be trained and then to be in
this position now where he's got him to
observe you know work for vader work for
a job of the hut he's got to really
observe how a lot of this has gone down
he probably knows how to run this thing
oh yeah he's probably been in every one
of those situations going oh here's how
i would do that he was i would do this
differently yeah
and i think what they've done here it
was quite a meditative episode i would
say uh and i like them a lot of it's
more especially in like the last 10
minutes of this
that felt very tone-poem and some more
it's more like ethereal dream like stuff
and
you know you i know star wars obviously
inspired by dune in many ways and then
here this was like in terms of live
action this felt very doom oh my
yeah and then it did it hit me in this
moment
um because usually when i hear about
usually when spice is brought up in star
wars a lot of the times uh
it's like it's mainly just about the
space travel yeah is what it's used for
and then
here
i like that you got a little bit of the
hallucinogenic quality
with it uh opening up the mind
uh the the references like psychedelic
drug use as well and then the way they
treat the tuscan raiders what are those
people called and dune who are the uh
the blue-eyed folk oh the fremen the
fremen yeah that's kind of what they
filled in here yeah a little bit of that
fremen quality yeah this is their domain
and they know it better than anyone and
i think they really elevated the tuscan
raiders as well at the before i'm not
gonna line i really gave a [ __ ] about
the tuscan writers so now oh there's so
much more personality down yeah what i
would have
liked to have gotten from the show at
least is just some moment really because
it was hitting me in the moments when
some of them were being killed off
was i would have liked to have had some
you know even though he can't have like
direct dialogue back and forth but still
build um
watch some of that relationship sort of
build because
the last episode ended off on
uh you know he's he helped save one of
them
and then they were like all right you're
cool yeah i'm not just going to punish
you now
and there's a bit of a time jump he's
training with them he helps them out but
i would have liked to have some scenes
that when we were feeling the loss of
some that way the loss of some of them
would hit a little bit more because even
though i like this a lot i really did
don't get me wrong i don't want this
misconstrue
i wanted to kind of get like the most
relationship he has with the guy has
been training him yeah you you kind of
beg a little for some kind of uh yeah
like connected more personal
relationship represented other than
functional relationships or
relationships that directly have
something to do with yeah his training
or you know the the greater stakes of
you know like everything with the train
and all that like yeah like they do such
a nice job uh to that effect of
conveying this tribal really lived in
vibe uh that yeah it's like and they
have this kid character too they do a
couple of charming things with but it
might have been nice to
get that sense of like what is endearing
him towards them other than this sense
of you know respect for their ability to
live amongst the elements and all that
sort of stuff
yeah well you know his the these people
uh like the tuscan raiders
[Music]
i love that they brought back to this is
their land
and how he brought them back into a
position
where you see this is the beginning
steps of where he's landed with taking
over like jabba's palace and such yeah
it's a really cool way to do that where
you start from really the nitty-gritty
part
of like the indigenous people getting to
be able to reclaim their land and the
way he helps because
there was something striking in the
sense that you know they they don't even
know how to use like speeder bikes which
seemed like such a common form of
transportation on tattooing and yet
they don't even know how to really
operate with that like they are still
very like all their weapons are very
handcrafted they still ride bantas as
methods of transportation we even have
creatures like the jawas who still have
like that are sand crawlers yeah you
know like these like massive cities yeah
they still are a lot more technical
technologically involved
and so what i think they did really well
is even though we didn't get some of
that personal relationship stuff that i
would have liked to have just a bit more
on
i wouldn't say that i don't care about
them i did find myself caring i didn't
find it like right it really sucks i at
least felt that like this really sucks
when i'm being killed off it's really
sad because you do
paint them here
where you do see that they are
you know beings with feelings and
they're not
it's like especially when you think
about like when they were first
introduced in a new hope to now where
they are now here
that i'm like oh i didn't realize just
how much um
character there was to unfold with them
um you know really unfolding like
especially with the tropicalistic
qualities and how there's several tribes
and how there's a lot of oppression that
essentially happened them and a lot of
loss which i'm sure boba can identify
with
in the sense of how he had like his home
planet is destroyed like one of the
earliest shots from this had been
the
like the shots of kamino which
if you watch bad patch
uh hey
[Laughter]
it's a lot of lore to keep up with but i
think they're filling in a lot of great
blanks and fleshing out
this journey in a way that is still
really riffing on
on like small town western and i think
that's what's cool about this is they
still keep it in star wars i'm so used
to like galactic scope
yeah yeah yeah and this they've really
embodied the small town western yeah i
mean it right down to i loved the
swapping out of like he doesn't bring
them horses he brings them speeder bikes
because that's the next logical step is
like yeah you have like you like you
said a lot of tangibles a lot of you
know very earthy means whether that be
transport by creature or handmade
weapons whereas here you know we're
going to get you the next step in you
know the evolutionary chain which is
greater technology so that you can
survive or level up in the world around
you and i think that's it's like the way
that this show is taken and and the
mandalorian by proxy also has taken like
a character that originally showed up
for brief appearances looked very cool
in a way i feel like there's a similar
thing happening with the tuscans where
it's like you know the initial
appearances you know they're another one
of the you know many
species of creatures who inhabit this
world but here you really get a sense
for the life that is lived by them and
the community that they are and i think
that they do a nice job of
not that every single one of them is
distinct there's a lot of uniformity but
they do a nice kind of subtle quiet job
of differentiating a few of them so that
it is impactful when you're losing
numbers and ranks and you know even
though we don't get very personal with
many of the tuscans it still feels
vital and intense when you have a small
crew of them trying to mount this train
and trying to you know
enact this
huge risk of a plan
and yeah like like the amount of breath
and air they were able to give this like
i think it's funny is you have the
present story which by all accounts
right now is quite
is inching along very sort of briefly as
he just basically has taken the throne
and is now trying to just get everyone
to accept that and so far just people
are showing up who are like nah not
about it and then we go into these long
passages of flashback
um but yeah i i love the way that
they're colliding in
a way that's like on one hand very
similar to the mandalorian but does it
feel like it's just the mandalorian but
with boba instead you know like they're
really good at exploring the various
ways in which you can apply the western
and even some of those like traveling
samurai
uh motifs to the star wars universe well
it's so it's more
it's a little more nitty gritty and down
and dirty yeah than anything from star
wars like when i say this is
teetering on like r-rated territory not
so far and not that i really expected
that
um
but it it definitely does have a
it's got a different pace about it it's
got a different energy and i think it
found it's more of its tone and footing
that i'm not sure will click for
everyone yeah because i'm like for a lot
of people they might perceive that a lot
of people will probably be like this is
really slow you know especially yeah
with how much just like signing and
alien languages there are yeah because
as much as there's more
you know communicative exchange that
occurs between him and the tuscan
raiders
it's still like
there's a lot of like non-dialogue that
does form from that
um
but i do like i just like tamara
morrison a lot he he has really great
child like smile yeah you know yeah
you can inhabit that almost like that
child like rage and then that child like
smile and i think what they've been what
they showed in that that like tattooing
tree moment
is
that this guy does have a really
traumatic past like he really is haunted
by he doesn't have a home
we saw his father beheaded
so much of his early journey was
getting involved in the wrong crowd
and
look and wanting seeking revenge against
uh mace windu
and then uh he gets hit by a blind guy
into this harlot
really gives you perspective on life
yeah so you are watching him become
reborn and i like how they are filling
in the blanks of
because you see him in like episode four
of mandalorian when he's whooping all
that ass and you're like wouldn't
freaking boba learn to be this bad yeah
like oh they're
really showing you that he
he lived in a different culture like he
got something very different and it's
like he started with like the first gang
help them reclaim that i think that's
really i think that is awesome i think
the train sequence was really well
realized too that was some really good
staging i mean some of it looked like
there are some shots that do definitely
look um
like when there's on the bike or
something like that look like
still looks like a previz
it's so freaking bright that it stands
out you could kind of tell yeah
um but more often than not i thought it
was really cool and really well done and
i like the
the quietness of it too
you know and it was neat it's a it's
funny there's so many and i and i love
it it makes for a really interesting
performance when you have partial sign
language and a lot of things especially
coming out of disney have characters
that speak partially in sign but i love
the kind of pace and intention that that
gives so many of the exchanges
especially between him and the tuscans
where it's like yeah you know he's got
to communicate very directly and simply
um but yeah i mean just hats off to tim
ware morrison
because
i feel like it would be easy to rest on
or or even just not have the you know
amazing chops or whatever but he's just
he's so great at every little attitude
he has to play both as this weather guy
who's seen a bunch but also this guy
who's learning the ropes and trying to
you know gain the trust of these people
around in this resourceful but also
thoughtful and kind of wise guy
and wise guy he's a wise guy he's a made
man now
all right i'm gonna pull i'm gonna pull
a reference here oh
and i think why this clicks to me is
like in some ways
this also is feeling like the breaking
bad slash better call saul version of
star wars sure it's not as slow it's not
as deliberate
but especially like with better call
saul of how that has
a little bit of a present and then we
watch a lot of the past and a lot of the
episodes do that
um but you know like also dealing with
like criminals the desert the heat the
sweat
yeah well just like the scarcity and and
the magic of water yeah yeah i think
that it has uh some qualities that i
just kind of naturally like a lot huh
pretty sure that shot of boba seeing as
a boy seeing his dad
fly off and sleep i'm pretty sure that's
a new shot i don't feel like that's
actually in the movie they've been i
think yeah they've been going back and
and making new shots in that scenario
hope they asked that kid
can we use your likeness and just
reanimate you into certain stuff don't
worry we'll we'll pay you for it oh
don't worry
but yeah there was some interesting
there was a nice uh blend of film style
i forget you you called out like a movie
or or a show or something that it
reminded you of at one point
um aside from dune obviously uh but yeah
there was like a little bit of dune in
there there was like a little mad max in
there
and uh even a little like
almost cowboy bebop-ish feeling stuff in
there
the live-action show the definitely the
definitive way that that supposed to be
experienced
undoubtedly
all right guys well what do you think
about this episode i give this a pretty
high one i feel like it's solid
because present day stuff i'm still not
super interested in what they're doing
it just feels so slight at the moment
yeah it's hard for me to care like
someone's trying to kill boba i don't
really know why boba wants to be in this
position and i don't really know
much about the world of what's going on
here
and and it's just it's like i mean i'm
interested to understand it um i'm not
exactly gravitated toward i'm more
gravitated towards the flashbacks is
what the show wants to care more about
yeah and there is something that i
didn't feel when watching the
mandalorian
where
i like fennec shand
individually yeah and i like tamora
morrison individually yes but something
about when they're talking to each other
their chemistry and rhythm feels a
little off with each other i can i can
meet you there it's there's something
that feels like it still needs to
i don't know whether it's the kinds of
scenes that they're giving them because
again most of the things in the present
are so kind of straightforward and
at least in these two episodes you kind
of get like here's sort of one major
beat for the present story and we're
going into the past and so i wonder
if they have a scene that's really them
directed at each other
and just you know
exchanging energy and you know dialogue
whatever back and forth i feel like
that
is what i'm missing so far for them
because like yeah she's
fenix shan has presents on her own it's
cool having them teamed up but at the
same time
you know it's pretty much her going you
need to like posture for these people a
little more and him being like i'm going
to do it my way and that's kind of their
whole dynamic right now is there
something about their dialogue back and
forth doesn't it feels like line reading
when they're talking to each other yeah
there's something that feels a little
unnatural and i didn't get that when i
watched mandalorian but no for certain
scenes here there's something that does
seem off when that when they are like at
the throne talking to you just going
back and forth or
after uh the cousin huts showed up i
feel like they're written to be
a little more like
we're cool and we don't say a whole lot
in all those senses it's like the note
in the writing
which is cool to behold but also is yeah
i wonder too for people like for
mandalorian season two fans
if you watch mandalorian and watch man
and learn season two i know season two
tied a lot more into the shows and
extended lore that from out of live
action
this in particular though i i i i wonder
if people will
will really care
you know what i mean because like for
them this
a lot of this it may not it's it's a lot
of trying to
i don't know we'll see yeah i think it
will people care and i think that
depends on just what the present day
point of all that is going to become and
two
i mean it seems like yeah part of this
is to flesh out this character and to
give him you know like the real uh meat
that a beloved character arguably ought
to have beyond an image well he's got
kind of a scarface story yeah yeah he
does he does and i mean part of me knows
that like okay but i think about i'm
sorry but really question my question is
is that is he going to change as a
character
or is he just going to rise to power
that's the question yeah you know
like how what what would his character
what would he
what does he have to arc into that he's
not arcing into in the past already yeah
yeah yeah like that that's kind of where
i'm
i don't really know what he's gonna look
like he might learn some stuff but how
is he gonna change as a person because
that's that's kind of where
the emotional hook of that is a little
lost on me yeah you know if you take i'm
not making i'm not saying it's just
because like man like i'll just use
mandalorians as an example you know a
detached
loner
bounty hunter
finds this
baby
and then grows into pretty much like a
protector and father
and
goes against his guidelines uh is his
his codes
you know finds connection and love yeah
like there's so much that happens with
him and with bob i'm like i'm not really
sure what his arc is you know like i say
scarface we're even talking about
breaking bad i'm like well that's them
descending yeah yeah this certainly
seems like he's not on that track yeah
all he stands to do i guess is just
prove to everybody that he's that big of
a badass and also kind of just about it
yeah cause i'm like i i know his goal
obviously but who is he going to change
i can't really what challenge to his
character yeah
because usually it's like you have a
goal but then what is that that
what will the our arc of the person
represent ultimately by the end of
achieving this goal yeah and it's like
so much of what we see we've seen it's
like in the flashbacks i have all these
ideas about like oh where this could go
and i bet we're going to see up until
the point that he finally crosses paths
with jinjaren and maybe that's how he
might factor into the season if he even
comes in but
yeah with the present it doesn't really
get me wondering
other than is he gonna be able to keep
all these people from trying to kill him
yeah you know it seems like the main
thing and also it would be cool if he
did sort of go like a michael corleone
path and godfather too where he just or
well father one even for that matter
yeah of
you know he sought this power he went
after it and that he
got worse
that would be neat yeah
or or finds himself in truly over his
head because too i mean he has
i mean they're good at drawing conflict
out of the idea that yeah he is crossing
paths with other people and taking on
their fights to an extent and that
presents a certain level of stakes
uh uh but you know is it the kind of
thing where maybe in the present he's
going to find that there are it's like
in the flashbacks and stuff like there's
a certain and anytime you see boba fett
there's a certain comfort that comes
along with oh he's got this handled he's
the biggest badass he's also super
resourceful and wise maybe
someone will come along this season to
you know knock him on his ass a bit
again and to get him you know in a place
of
you know needing to overcome whatever
personal limitation like it doesn't
sound great when i'm saying it out loud
uh but maybe it could be that kind of
thing to then go against that just
innate safety you feel of like he's a
badass he's got this handled yeah you
know maybe somebody who really is as
tough as they say might step in and give
him some real problems or something like
that or
i guess i just don't foresee them going
full-on into like oh
there's a descent into you know
something really heavy because i feel
like they're they're not gonna they're
already having to make him more likeable
than a regular bounty hunter and more
like morally agreeable than that so i
kind of don't foresee it but it would be
interesting if they tried it if they do
it you know yeah
we'll see
still got a few more to go
all right guys we'll leave your thoughts
down below subscribe hit that bell thank
you prepper boys last but not least
lance door if there's anybody out there
who would be perfect to teach us to be
resourceful in desolate lands in times
of great need and oppression it would be
you you could get us whipped into shape
with all sorts of practical firefighting
techniques and even if we're like hey
what does this have to do with robbing a
space train you would not only be the
sage boba fett type leader who gets us
into shape and mentally fortified for
battle but she would also be kind of
like a mr miyagi type where you get us
you know focused in on the true zen of
life and through that we would be the
baddest ass warriors in all of star wars
fandoms so uh lance come up with a
workout regimen you know teach us how to
fashion our own weapons we'll do
anything you say you don't even have to
come up with a good regimen you could
just you know give us a couple of things
you know to keep us busy and we'll do
them you could tell me to do anything
right now and i'm gonna do it because i
trust you because that's how much
experience and wisdom you have i just
hope that this message reaches you
safely and that you're doing well in the
year of our lord 2022 love you buddy
you know usually when people are tired
they talk less oh
lance and somehow not excuses
i want to make it good for lance
i was just like lance i can't fail lance
today he's like what is he talking about
for the last 90 seconds right now
lance knows
i don't think he does
[Music]